GUTFELD'S NEXT.
>> HAPPY FRIDAY.
I'M NOT YOUR DOCTOR, BUT I CAN
HEAL YOU.
WHAT A WEEK FOR FREE SPEECH
FIRST ELON MUSK BUYS TWITTER SO
ALL SIDES COULD BE HEARD COMING
IT'S LIKE A COP AND A MOVIE THA
OPENS THE TRUNK OF THE CAR
DEFINED SOMEBODY'S BOUND AND
GAGGED.
WHO HASN'T BEEN THERE, RIGHT?
IT'S OVER LIKE MINE AT THE
PLANET FITNESS STEAM ROOM.
IF IT'S LEGAL, HAVE ADDED.
WITHIN THE WHITE HOUSE ANNOUNCE
THE MINISTRY OF DISINFORMATION
TO MONITOR YOUR SPEECHES OF BOT
APPEARANCE IN YOU'RE A NEWBORN
IN THE CRIB IN THE NEXT ROOM.
SO THE PEOPLE LYING WANT TO BE
THE ARBITERS OF TRUTH GREAT
THAT'S WHAT SETH MEYERS TO FOR
CITING SOMETHING IS FUNDING.
YOU'RE NOT TO BELIEVE THIS.
HERE IS THE LADY RUNNING THE
THING.
♪ SINGING ♪
>> THAT'S IT FOR ESTIMATES.
MAYBE SHE'S RIGHT, SOME FORMS O
SPEECH SHOULD BE BANNED.
NOW THE GOVERNMENT THANKS YOUR
SPEECH IS DANGEROUS.
THEN, WHICH IS IRONIC FOR PEOPL
WHOSE WORDS FOR RESPONSIBLE FOR
PEOPLE DYING DURING PROBATE OR
WHOSE WORDS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
SENDING YOUNG PEOPLE OFF TO DIE
IN POINTLESS WAR SPREAD THE
GOVERNMENT HOLDS THE REINS ON
TRUTH GREAT RAINS, NOT WHIPS
LIKE IN RECENT DISINFORMATION
FROM THE GOVERNMENT.
ITS WEIRD TO SEE WHO IS HAPPY
AND WHO ISN'T VERY.
>> WHEN HE SAYS WELCOME OF THIS
IS ABOUT FREE SPEECH, IT SEEMS
THAT IT'S ABOUT FREE SPEECH OF
STRAIGHT WHITE MEN.
>> THE RIGHT HAS ALREADY SEIZED
IN THIS GROUND OF FREE SPEECH,
THEY'RE NOT THE POLITICAL
VERSION OF YELLING FIRE AND A
MOVIE THEATER.
>> HUMUS IS THE OLD HUMAN ONCE
THAT BASSFORD.
>> ELON MUSK BUYING TWITTER SAY
A LOT ABOUT PEOPLE AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS MAKING DECISIONS
THAT COULD AFFECT THE FATE OF
THE PLANET.
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN THEM THIS
UNHAPPY SINCE ... BUT THESE ARE
PEOPLE AND THE MEDIA MELTING
DOWN.
THEY WANT TO CONTROL THE
MARKETPLACE OF IDEAS BECAUSE
THIS IS ABOUT WHO CAN SPEAK,
IT'S ABOUT WHO CAN BE HEARD.
WHEN ANYONE CAN SPEAK THEIR MIND
, WHY WOULD YOU LISTEN TO
NICOLE WALLACE.
COME ON, IT'S MUCH AS THEY
DISLIKE MY OPINIONS IN IS MUCH
AS I MAKE FUN OF THEIR WEIGHT,
YOU ASSUME WE'D ALL AGREE ON A
RIGHT TO SAY THIS STUFF.
WITH A FREE PASS.
I WOULD NEVER CENSOR SOMEONE
JUST BECAUSE HE STINKS OF
BUTTERMILK PANCAKES.
RACHEL MADDOW SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO LIE ABOUT MOTION AND I
SHOULD BE ABLE TO LIE TO AFTER
ALL, WHY SHOULD THE SECOND
AMENDMENT BE THE ONLY WHEN THE
MEDIA IN GOVERNMENT HAVE USED.
SOON THE ONLY RIGHT WILL HAVE
LEFT IS THAT WE CAN'T BE
COMPELLED TO SHELTER BRITISH
SOLDIERS ALTHOUGH I'LL MAKE IN
EXCEPTION FOR YOU.
THE COUCH IS A FOLDOUT.
AND NOT JUST THE COUCH.
BUT IT'S ALL ABOUT LEFT-WING
CONFORMITY IN THEIR
CONSOLIDATION OF POWER.
WILLINGLY THOUGHT IT WOULD BE O
CAMPUS AND NOW THE ONLY THING
THE LEFT WANTS FREE AFTER
COLLEGE'S STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
HOW DID THIS ALL SINK INTO REAL
LIFE?
I UNDERESTIMATED THE FEAR THESE
FREAKS COULDN'T STILL IN OTHER
SPREAD WE DIDN'T REALIZE SO MUC
WEIGHT CALLING YOU A RACIST
COULD BEAR ON THEM FOR THEY SAY
IT'S TANTAMOUNT TO MICHAEL MOOR
SITTING ON THE NEWBORN BABIES
JUST CHEST FOR 45 MINUTES.
AND UNDERESTIMATED HOW MANY
COWARDS WOULD CAVE INTO THIS
FORM OF DOMESTIC TERRORISM.
THAT'S RIGHT, CANCELING PEOPLE'
LIVES BECAUSE SOMETHING THEY
SAID IT IS TERRORISM, NOT
RAISING YOUR VOICE TO A SCHOOL
BOARD.
UNLIKE THE SUMMER OF LOVE, THE
LEFT NEED TO TUNE IN, TURN IN
AND DROP OUT WHERE THEY APPLY
FOR BIG JOBS AT BIG COMPANIES.
EVEN MY MASSEUSE HAS FOUR
PRONOUNS, I NEVER USE THEM.
THE C DECLINE IN FREEDOM IN FUN
THERE THEY ARE.
IT REMINDS MORE KOREA DEFECTORS
OF HOME.
THEY TARGET STUFF THAT WAS ON
OFF-LIMITS.
YOUR JOB YOUR SAFETY.
THINGS THAT USED TO COME UNDER
THE CATEGORY OF NONE OF YOUR
BUSINESS.
EVERYTHING YOU SAY IS NOW A
TRIPWIRE.
I SAY MAYBE THAT IS THE GOAL.
THEY NEVER LIKE THIS PLACE TO
BEGIN WITH GREAT TIERNEY,
AUTHORITARIANISM.
THEY FOCUS ON BUREAUCRATS, MEDIA
, WITH POWER AND REPLACE
THEM WITH LITTLE TYRANTS
DEDICATED TO THE LEFT WING AND
NOW HATE SPEECH IS ALL SPEECH
EXCEPT THERE IS GREAT IT'S IT
FLICKS THE HIPPOCRATIC OATH.
IT'S LIKE ATHLETES DENOUNCING
WINNING GREAT IT'S LIKE ME
CONDEMNING SCULPTED PACKS.
THEY CHOSE THE HORSE POSITION
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT YOURS AND
CONDEMN THINGS ONLY BECAUSE YOU
MIGHT BE FOR THEM.
THIS HAPPENS WHEN YOU MAKE THE
POLITICAL PERSONAL THEY GO AFTE
COPS, MOMS, DADS, KIDS, SPEECH,
WHAT COULD BE NEXT?
YOU CAN SEE ABOUT THE LEFTIST
TABLES, BUT UNAMBITIOUS, THAT'S
NOT ONE OF THEM AND WITH ENEMIE
LIKE THAT, WHO NEEDS RUSSIA?
>> TONIGHT'S GUEST IS WIDER THA
A CAULIFLOWER SANDWICH ON WONDE
BREAD, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
>> GUIDING SHIFTS AND THE FOG.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
THAT MAN NO ONE COULD PICK UP,
THE NWA WORLD TELEVISION
CHAMPIONS, TYRUS.
YOU SEEING IN A BARBERSHOP
QUARTET?
>> OH, BOY.
>> USUALLY FOUND SOMEBODY YOU
COULD MOCK.
>> I DON'T OVERHEAR GOING WITH
THAT.
>> NORMALLY PEOPLE WOULD MAKE
FUN OF YOU, BUT THERE IS NOTHIN
QUITE LIKE HIM, BUT THAT WAS
HORRENDOUS.
>> IT WAS REALLY QUITE AMAZING.
SHE IS A RIDICULOUS PERSON IN
WERE ALL LAUGHING AT HER.
I THINK THAT THE WHOLE COUNTRY
WILL LAUGH AT HER, BUT YOU CAN'
FORGET IT'S NOT JUST THAT SHE'S
A RIDICULOUS PERSON BECAUSE
SERIOUS PEOPLE ARE DOING WHAT
SHE'S DOING AS WELL.
THE OTHER DAY I HEARD OBAMA SAY
THE SAME THING PRETTY SAID I'M
FREE SPEECH ABSOLUTIST.
YOU CAN'T SAY THINGS THAT AREN'
TRUE.
>> THAT'S THE WHOLE IDEA, YOU
CAN SAY THINGS THAT AREN'T TRUE.
I'M SICK OF HEARING THE PHRASE
ABOUT THE THEATER.
YOU CAN'T YELL FIRE AND A
THEATER.
YES, YOU CAN.
YOU CAN YELL FIRE AND A THEATER
FOR MANY REASONS, FOR ONE, WHEN
THERE'S A FIRE AND THE THEATER,
TO WHEN YOU THINK THERE'S A FIR
AND THE THEATER.
YOU'RE ALLOWED TO SAY THINGS, S
YOU'RE ALLOWED TO BE WRONG AND
JUST LIKE YOU SAID, WHEN OBAMA
SAID SOMETHING, WHEN WE USED TO
DO SHOWS, OBAMA WOULD SAY
SOMETHING AND WE WOULD SAY NO,
WE DISAGREE WITH HIM AND THAT'S
THE ANSWER.
YOU'RE ALLOWED TO SAY THINGS
THAT AREN'T TRUE.
I THINK THESE PEOPLE HAVE FAILE
BEFORE THEY BEGUN.
THIS THING IS IDIOTIC AND I
DON'T THINK ANYONE WILL TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY.
I'M CELEBRATING THAT I FEEL LIK
THIS DISINFORMATION HAS FAILED
BEFORE IT'S BEGUN.
>> HOW DID THE DEMOCRATS AND
SENT ON THE WRONG SIDE OF THIS?
IS KIND OF CRAZY.
>> THEY SAID FREE SPEECH WAS A
RIGHT-WING.
THEY'VE JUST DECIDED TO COME OU
RIGHT AND, I MEAN NOBODY COULD
PERFORM THIS TASK.
NAME ME THE PERSON YOU THINK
SHOULD DECIDE WHAT ALL OF US CA
SAY, THERE IS NO SUCH PERSON, N
SUCH PERSON IN THE LAND.
BUT THIS LADY.
IRENE OF ALL THE ONES COMING YO
GET THE MARY POPPINS WEIRD
DISINFORMATION SONG PERSON?
THEY HAVE BEEN WRONG ON SO MANY
THINGS.
AND THEN SHE THOUGHT THE LAPTOP
SHOULD BE SUPPRESSED FOR IT.
>> SHE SAID IT WAS A PRODUCT OF
TROVES CAMPAIGN.
SHE ALSO DEFENDED THAT LETTER
FROM LIKE THE 50 INTEL PEOPLE.
ALL LIES.
SHE'S BEEN WRONG ON THE BIG
STORIES, AND WHEN THEY DEFEND
HER, I JUST WANT TO SAY WHAT
WHAT ABOUT YOU YOU SAID TAKING
PEOPLE FROM THE SOUTHERN BORDER
AND SHIPPING THEM AROUND THE
COUNTRY IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT BECAUSE THAT WAS 3:00 A.M
AND THAT DIDN'T COUNT AS MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
THEY LIE ALL THE TIME GREAT
EVERYONE IN MY EXPERIENCE THAT
TALKS ABOUT MISINFORMATION
OBSESSIVELY, IS THE ONE DOING IT
.
>> TYRUS, THIS FEELS LIKE A
GREAT WEEK IF YOU LOVE FREE
SPEECH, RIGHT?
IF YOU'RE UNHAPPY POLITICALLY
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED THIS WEEK,
YOU MIGHT WANT TO RETHINK YOUR
POLITICS.
LIKE IF THIS BOTHERS YOU.
>> I THINK IT SAD THAT WE HAVE
TO BE EXCITED ABOUT SOMEONE
SAYING HEY, LET'S JUST BE NORMAL
.
HEY, EVERYONE, JUST AGREED TO
DISAGREE OR YOU DISAGREE BUT
EVERYONE GETS A VOICE.
THAT SHOULDN'T BE A BIG THING.
I THINK THE HORRIBLE NEWS IS
JULIE ANDREWS, WHAT DID SHE DO?
WHAT DID SHE DO TO DESERVE TO B
MOCKED LIKE THAT?
THAT WAS BRUTAL.
AND I DISAGREE A LITTLE BIT,
SOMEBODY COULD BE ON THE BOARDS
BOARD OF DISINFORMATION IF THEY
OWN THEIR OWN.
IF SHE WOULD'VE CAME OUT AND
SAID I WOULD MAKE UP A LINE AND
SAY MY KIDS WERE BEING KIDNAPPE
OR SOMETHING.
IF SHE WOULD'VE COME OUT AND
SAID I WAS SORRY.
I'M GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
ARE WRONG ABOUT SOMETHING.
IT DOESN'T MEAN IT GOES AWAY.
BUT THAT WOULD TAKE A REALLY
REALLY BRAVE AND HONEST PERSON.
>> PROBABLY A BILLIONAIRE THAT
DOESN'T GAIN ANYTHING.
>> THE FACT THAT SHE COULD TAKE
THIS JOB WITHOUT ADMITTING THAT.
>> SHE WILL GO DOWN ON THAT
STUFF.
>> KAT, YOU HATE FREEDOM AND YO
HATE SPEECH.
>> TALK FREELY.
IS NOT FUNNY THOUGH TO SEE
DEMOCRATS COMING OUT AGAIN
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
EVERYTHING IS TURNED UPSIDE DOWN
.
>> I'M HAVING A HARD TIME
UNDERSTANDING.
IT'S JUST OBJECTIVELY RIDICULOU
TO HAVE THIS ANTI-
DISINFORMATION BOARD LED BY
SOMEONE WHO IS FAMOUS FOR
FIGHTING DISINFORMATION.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW EVERYBOD
IS NOT MAD ABOUT THIS IN
POINTING OUT HOW ABSURD IT IS.
IF THERE IS A REASON YOU'RE NOT
IT'S BECAUSE IT'S A DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATION IN YOU'RE A
DEMOCRAT THEN YOU'RE TOO STUPID
FOR THEIR EVEN TO BE WORDS FOR
THAT.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT ALWAYS GOING
TO BE A DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATION AND WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT CREATE SOMETHING IT
DOESN'T USUALLY GO AWAY AFTER
THAT.
SO IT WHEN IT'S NOT DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATION THIS WILL STILL
BE THERE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW EVERYBOD
IS NOT UPSET ABOUT THIS.
>> I THINK DANA MADE A GOOD
POINT ON THE FIVE YESTERDAY.
VERY RARE.
THAT DEMOCRATS DON'T HAVE
SOMEBODY THAT IS SENSIBLE TO
TELL THEM THIS WAS A BAD IDEA.
THEY GOTTEN RID OF ALL THOSE
PEOPLE.
THE MINISTRY OF TRUTH, IS THAT
WHAT THEY HAD CALLED.
THERE IS NOBODY THERE TO TELL
THEM THEY DON'T HAVE A HISTORY.
A, I DON'T THINK IT'S HAPPENING.
IF THEY DO,.
>> THAT'S THE ONLY WAY THEY CA